so I wanted to touch on the huge
relationship between your digestive
system your gut your friendly bacteria
and your mood okay specifically anxiety
stress and worry and even the effect on
cognitive functions like lack of focus
or concentration if you don't have all
the microflora the friendly bacteria in
your digestive system specifically
Bifidobacterium and lactobacillus it can
potentially - all sorts of problems with
your brain chemistry now if you
experience a loss of a loved one it's
normal to have depression if you're
being chased by a tiger it is normal to
have anxiety and stress but what I want
to touch on is what if there's actually
no reason to have depression anxiety
stress or worry I want to touch on the
actual physical causation of that
because your microbes actually make
proteins and I'm talking about
neurotransmitters neurotransmitters are
hormone like proteins that travel
through the you nervous system like gaba
for example if you're lacking gaba but
you can be depressed and then you have
serotonin in its relationship to your
mood do you realize that 90% of all the
serotonin in your body is made by your
gut only 10% is made by your brain and
there's other neurotransmitters that are
made by your gut as well so if you do
not have the right ratios of microbes if
you don't have enough microbes that can
have huge effect over your body's
ability to make neurotransmitters then
you have something called the enteric
nervous system now I've done other
seminars where I talked about the flight
or fight mechanism it's called the
sympathetic nervous system and then you
have the rest and digest system which is
the parasympathetic there's actually a
third system of the autonomic nervous
system that is called the enteric which
is really the connection between all the
nerves in your gut and the direct
connection to your brain so what is
going on down here can definitely affect
up here so how do we lose our micro
flora well mainly through antibiotics
now you might say well I don't take any
buttocks I probably had antibiotics as a
child but I haven't had them for years
but guess what over 80% of antibiotics
are sold as a growth factor for farm
animals okay so you're basically giving
antibiotics indirectly if you're
consuming commercial meats and that's
why I always recommend consuming organic
I will do a separate video on this but
organic means without the use of
pesticides insecticides and GMO foods
like glyphosate as well as without
antibiotics so I recommend doing that
but it's sometimes it's hard if you're
going to going out to dinner because you
don't really know what you're getting
artificial sweeteners
greatly affect the microflora and your
gut as well so if you're on a diet soda
for a long period of time that could
affect your microflora and lastly the
GMO foods which we're all affected by
glyphosate as an herbicide greatly
disrupts our micro flora and it can
affect our ability to make proteins so
there's a couple things you can do that
are very simple to improve these three
symptoms right here take a probiotic
take a good one that includes these two
as well get a probiotic and a prebiotic
together as in sauerkraut kimchi pickles
fermented vegetables when I'm at the
farmers market I always get a fermented
vegetable and I consume some fermented
vegetables on a daily basis that way you
can kill two birds with one stone
because the prebiotic is the fiber and
then it has a probiotic as well and that
can help you and avoid the things that
destroy your micro flora these right
here these right here these right here
and by the way long-term use of
laxatives can really throw off your
micro flora I'll put a couple links down
below if you have constipation so
anything that affects diarrhea
medication laxatives or even things that
you're eating that are like food
allergies that are creating that problem
will throw this off and effect these
right here all right guys thanks for
watching
hey before you go would you mind putting
a comment down below to tell me what you
think about this video